any parting thoughts for our folks
watching specifically like you know
let's say the individual retail investor
audience who's watching
any parting thoughts for them advice
so um
i have some prior work experience in the
wealth management space and then i did
about two years on the commercial
banking side and i think one of the main
things that i learned
and one of the perspectives that i
gained during kind of my professional
experience is that people under the age
of 45 should generally be a net buyer of
assets in order to um just basically
grow our nest egg grow our wealth and
basically kind of secure our retirement
and so
um for people who have earnings power
like whether that's fifty dollars a
month or five thousand dollars a month
or twenty thousand dollars a month like
i think people should generally be
dollar cost averaging into the markets
where they fall on the risk spectrum is
up to them and they're kind of um
basically like their own risk tolerance
but
from my perspective like
things right now are just unequivocally
on sale when you have companies like
google that were down more than 30
off their 52-week highs that happened
earlier this year or amazon was down
more than 45 percent like these are
phenomenal companies that are just
continuing to grow at a rapid pace but
have been severely repriced because of
the rise in yields yields aren't going
to stay high forever they're eventually
going to come back down we don't know
how long that's going to be and so i
think generally speaking when you have
the opportunity to buy great companies
or great assets that you have long-term
conviction in
you comment you have to be willing to
stomach some of the short-term
volatility that we have in the market
right now so
this was something that i was also
saying to family and friends in march
and april of 2020 i thought the market
was going to go lower than the march
23rd lows but i was still allocating to
risk assets in that environment so
it's okay to simultaneously be
increasing your exposure to risk assets
while also thinking risk assets might be
going lower we also don't know what we
don't know so risk assets could have
bottomed and we don't want to miss the
boat so we again we have to just kind of
humble ourselves in terms of recognizing
that the market is way smarter than we
are
no matter how smart we may think we are
and
i think like i said if you're basically
under the age of 45 you should generally
be increasing your exposure
to assets over time